despedidas al 2020 marcadas por el
impacto de la pandemia de oriente a
occidente líderes mundiales se
despidieron de un año determinado por el
hobbit 19 el presidente chino se mostró
orgulloso de los esfuerzos de su país
por hacerle frente carling ar link 2020
fue un año extraordinario frente al
brote repentino de la pandemia del nuevo
coronavirus colocamos a las personas ya
sus vidas en la máxima prioridad y
logramos el gran amor de la humanidad
con solidaridad y perseverancia
escribimos la epopeya de nuestra lucha
contra la epidemia
el mandatario estadounidense elogió sus
esfuerzos para encontrar una vacuna
gracias a la operación words speed
desarrollamos una vacuna en sólo nueve
meses y ya comenzamos un programa de
vacunación a nivel nacional y estamos
enviando la vacuna a todo el mundo
el presidente ruso vladimir putin llamó
a la unión para superar la segunda ola
de contagios que afronta su país en los
tiempos difíciles pasan siempre pasan y
las cosas más importantes permanecen con
nosotros lo que nos hace nobles y
fuertes y si el amor el entendimiento
mutuo la confianza y el apoyo entonces
me gustaría pedir un deseo a que las
dificultades del año saliente pronto
quedarán en el olvido y todo lo ganado
quedará para siempre uno en su último
discurso en 15 años la canciller alemana
quiso recordar a las víctimas que dejó
la pandemia escandón sólo puedo imaginar
lo amargo que se debe sentir por
aquellos seres amados que están de luto
y los fallecidos por el coronavirus y
aquellos que tienen que luchar contra
las repercusiones de una enfermedad
cuando el virus es disputado por algunos
individuos
por su parte el presidente francés dijo
que los meses venideros serán duros
donde mi infancia fue en 2021 pase lo
que pase podremos afrontar la crisis
sanitaria económica social terrorista y
climática que no desaparece en el
primero de enero
los primeros meses del año serán
difíciles y al menos hasta la primavera
la epidemia pensará mucho sobre la vida
en nuestro país
y como muchos otros líderes macrón
centró sus esperanzas en las campañas de
vacunación que se desarrollarán en 2021